Howard Kurtz is the media buzz host for
the Fox News Channel and the author of
the latest book media ban is Donald
Trump the press and the war over the
truth good morning good morning to you
could you connect the dots between those
things the president the press and this
matter of truth what are you trying to
say I'm trying to say as a
scorched-earth warfare going on between
the two sides now in every
administration you said you read my book
spin cycle about the Clinton White House
there was a national natural adversarial
tension between the two but we have
never seen anything like this we have
never seen such unrelentingly negative
coverage often very personal harshly
personal I would say in nature as we are
seeing against this president and we
have never seen a president of the
United States constantly on the attack
against the news business fake news
dishonest media and I think it's
damaging both sides but my great concern
in writing this as a lifelong journalist
is that it's damaging the press more how
has the press changed released coverage
of the presidency changed because of the
president so far well I mean we saw this
beginning in the campaign when you know
first of all the press the pundits as a
whole didn't take Donald Trump all that
seriously he was a sideshow it was very
entertaining but of course he wasn't
gonna make it to Iowa he would never win
the nomination and everybody knew and he
was not gonna beat Hillary Clinton you
know your previous guest was talking
about her beyond that you know there
were all these gloom and doom prophecies
about you know this controversy will
finish you off well I'll never survive
this one we see that again now there is
a sense in the mainstream press that
week some many say that we can't
normalize Donald Trump's presidency what
does that tell you first of all it tells
you they view him as unfit for office
many not all many reporters are fair and
that they view him as you know you've
heard all the words unhinged mentally
unbalanced incompetent but also a
dictator it's interesting the range of
descriptions of this president at the
same time this is a book that goes
behind the scenes at the Trump White
House right I talked about how the
president suffers in his aides
description from Defiance disorder they
tell him not to do something he does it
anyway because nobody tells Donald Trump
what to do and there were times when it
is very effective for him to lash out at
the press which he thinks and what
his supporters believe is treating him
very unfairly and there were times when
he goes too far or distracts from his
own agenda you tell a story in the book
about meeting Donald Trump and he said
things to you about how he views trevor
has particularly negative coverage what
did he say
well I interviewed the the now president
a half-dozen times during the campaign
in fact I first met him in the late
1980s in New York and that's one of the
reasons I did underestimate him in the
campaign I saw his media mastery as a
New York guy what he said to me was that
he couldn't get over the fact that some
commentators in his view have hatred for
him used that word hatred and he is a
counter puncher and so somebody hates
him he hates back on them but at the
same time he was kind of wounded by that
and there was a love/hate relationship
in way missed mostly eight right now
with this president because he really
wants the approval of the media he
always got good media coverage by and
large when he was a businessman reality
TV show guy and so forth a year ago he
had private off-the-record meeting with
network anchor is in which they asked
him his biggest surprise as president he
says it's that you guys never changed
your coverage once I became president
and this of course dovetails with all
the major events of his presidency the
Charlottesville tragedy the Russia
investigation which is back in the news
he is just convinced he's not getting a
fair shake but he also meets privately
with people like NBC's Chuck Todd I
explained in the book and other is
because there's a way in which he works
the refs he's trying to win them over
he's done it with me I even write in the
book apart this he said Donald Trump is
staking his presidency as he did his
election on nothing less than destroying
the credibility of the news media and
the media are determined to do the same
to him you go on but expand on that in
light of what you just said yeah well
you know there is now it's actually it
turns out to be good box office for
major news organizations you turn them
on at night they're these panels six to
one against Trump who are sort of
largely appealing to an anti Trump
audience it may be good business but the
problem is there is a whole chunk of the
country 63 million Americans who voted
for Donald Trump many still
enthusiastically support this president
and to them not only do they think that
their guy their champion is being
treated unfairly but they believe what
some justification as I write in media
Madness that the elite media
Stickley here in Washington New York la
look down on them view them
condescendingly there's one headline
I'll never forget in the left-leaning
Huffington Post a vote for Trump was a
hate crime well that kind of
condescending attitude does undercut the
credibility of the media among those who
are not within this particular bubble
Howard Kurtz our guest he is the media
bus host on the Fox News Channel and
also the author of the book medium a
dystonic Trump the press and the war
over the troop if you want to ask him
questions about the coverage of Donald
Trump President Trump by the media
you can call 202 seven four eight eight
thousand one for Republicans 202 semper
eighty eight thousand for Democrats
independents 202 seven four eight eight
thousand two and you can also tweet us
your thoughts at c-span WJ does
president Trump enjoy a relationship
with certain then type of conservative
media who speak favorably about him
would you say Fox News as part of that I
have some thoughts on that first of all
in the campaign president told me he
thought Fox News was treating him
unfairly obviously he's revised that
view but there are a number of prominent
conservative commentators some of whom
work at Fox people at National Review
weekly standard who were never Trump in
the campaign who were still a pretty
critical of this president so even
though he's a conservative Republican
president he doesn't enjoy a cheering
squad on the right obviously there were
some and obviously primetime hosts on
Fox News and Fox and Friends are much
more sympathetic to this president let's
say than the other cable news channels
at the same time the president sometimes
you know when he is pushing back against
the media and I write examples of this I
think he shouldn't be punching down at
individual Cable News host I think
that's beneath him sometimes he does it
as a strategy to take the spotlight off
of something else other times it's just
you know it is actually good politics
for him it plays very well with his most
loyal supporters to beat up on a news
missus that they don't trust anyway and
the lack of trust the diminishing trust
this hasn't been happening for decades
long before Donald Trump was in politics
I think is what is eroding a business
that I love that I grew up in that I
want to be perceived as fair and I think
right now it's the cool thing to do is
to be against Donald Trump in fact to
question is he going to survive is he
mentally able to
analyst office and that seems to a lot
of people to be unfair when it comes to
cover to the White House's party or
concerns is what happens for the next
presidents after Donald Trump's
influence on this media right and beyond
that there will be a time when Donald
Trump is no longer president whether
it's in three years or seven years and I
think some of the wounds some of them
self-inflicted that the media are
inflicting on themselves where they're
seen as one-sided where people don't
trust the fact checkers anymore which is
a problem because we are not agreeing on
a basic set of facts everybody's in
their own ideological bubbles I think
the damage being done now this is not to
say that some of the reporting on
president hasn't been good that some of
the investigative reporting on him
hasn't been spot-on but collectively
damage being done now I believe is going
to last far beyond Donald Trump's
presidency
first call for you comes from Joe and
Joe is in Valley Cottage New York our
line for Republicans you're on with
Howard Kurtz go ahead good morning guys
Howie just want to say I watch your show
every Sunday you have a very you're the
epitome of fair and balanced thank you
you have a terrific show and I wish that
they would give you a weekly show which
would be great anyway Howie the reason I
called was Fox has been stressing lately
about the uranium one incident about
selling American uranium the president
has mentioned that Senator John Barrasso
wrote an article in the opinions section
of the Wall Street Journal data from
Thursday February 8th 2018 which
discusses this whole thing I would be
great if you could have the senator on
your show I don't know if you're
familiar with the article possibly Pedro
could bring it up but uh it clears up a
lot of stuff about why we have a
shortage of uranium and what's actually
going on Thank You Howie thank you
you know I don't think there's any
question that somebody who covered this
campaign intensively if there was a lot
of influence peddling and attempted
influence peddling surrounding the
Clinton Foundation surrounding the
former president speeches at the same
time
and I'm not saying none of this should
be looked at but Hillary Clinton lost
the election she's not president she's
not going to be President and I think
that some people who excessively focus
on her
are in part trying to deflect attention
from the investigations of President
Trump now I will jump in here and add
we've had about a year investigations
now we just had last week of the Bob
Muller indictments against 13 Russians
which didn't find any active collusion
on the part of anybody associated with
Donald Trump so we don't know where this
will end up but that focus of the
investigation seems not to have
unearthed a whole lot at the same time
president's dismissing in his fake news
and a hoax well it's not a hoax it's a
real investigation they've been guilty
pleas and indictments lately most
recently against these 13 Russians now
so I think it's really important for the
press to be fair in covering this
investigation it is news it is it is a
serious investigation that much is clear
at the same time we shouldn't be seen to
sometimes on nighttime cable hyping
every incremental development into the
next Watergate if everything's at 11:00
then nothing's in 11 independent line
from North Carolina Sandra hello yes I
just want to say Howard do you do a
great job and the reason I watch Fox
News is because they tell the truth and
I'll turn over to another station just
to say see what they're saying and it's
like a lie it's like they don't put
everything into it and everything and I
just believe in Fox News because they
tell the truth they're getting you know
like Hannity I love Hannity he is so
awesome Tucker awesome and I just want
to say keep it up you do a great job and
I know your heart is in the media just
keep it up you know because we look for
you we look to the truth to you because
we know you tell the truth the rest of
media does not tell a thérèse I'm sorry
to say they do not they've just
completely lost it just like the
Democrats thank you thank you for the
kind words
I mean I've written a whole book about
what I think is is often unfair company
of the president but I know I wouldn't
go so far as to say none of the other
media telling the truth I do think many
journalists have an agenda and part of
what I write about in media man this is
what they say privately our President
Trump what they say on Twitter when they
think the only their pals are listening
new such as what such as the New York
Times before
who said privately during the campaign
to an RNC staff member the Donald Trump
is a racist and a fascist and that those
in the Republican Party supporting him
we're also complicit in that racism and
fascism such as a Wall Street Journal
reporter who said on Twitter after the
president pulled out of the Paris
climate deal that he was threatening the
planet just to appease his base after
four months in office Sean Spicer called
and complained and he deleted that tweet
so it's that kind of thing and by the
way since Fox came up you know we have a
news division people like me Chris
Wallace Bret Baier and Henry who try to
be journalists and cover the president
fairly and that doesn't means it's not
always favorable and then we have
opinion people and she seems to be a big
fan of hannity and tucker and obviously
they are paid for their opinions well
what strikes you when she says she sees
the truth but she points to the opinion
is that a concern for you I think most
viewers readers people who consume news
online are pretty sophisticated about
this stuff you look people there's a
natural tendency to like people who
agree with your worldview and so the
people who love Rachel Maddow on MSNBC
probably most of them are very liberal
she's a smart road scholar if she goes
too far I say so but you know I
understand that kind of it's an almost
tribal loyalty these days in this hyper
partisan media atmosphere I just find
the need to remind people and this is
true at CNN and MSNBC and it's true on
the New York Times which has an
editorial page and an op-ed page that
are separate from the news pages that
there were people who at least are in
the business of trying to be to coin a
phrase fair and balanced and others who
are conservative liberal libertarian who
are in the business of giving opinions
Democrats line from Atlanta Georgia
Michele you're on with Howard Kurtz yes
Pedro I don't believe nothing that this
man is spouting out Donald Trump is a
bigot he's a racist he's a narcissist
and he's a Klansmen I don't believe
anything coming out of the mouth of the
Republican Party they are they Michelle
Michelle since we Michelle since we have
our guest right here why don't you
address your question or comment
directly to him
Michelle are you there all he wants you
but for eight years we as Democrats have
to sit here and listen to the Republican
party dog our President Obama but let me
tell you something it's going to be a
new day in 2018 because every black
every brown every Democrat are going out
there and we're gonna show this fool
that sitting up here trying to glow if I
try okay we'll leave it there because we
invited him as our guests we don't want
to insult him but you've seen a lot of
media coverage of administration's did
President Obama get a pass from the
media well in the 2008 campaign I've
never seen a presidential candidate
softer treatment in Barack Obama did I
think even many of his fans would not
dispute that I think he had a pretty
easy first term I think got Rufford
coverage in the second term when he with
a Republican Congress had a lot of
trouble getting things through and was
sort of checkmated on in areas like
Syria look the the caller there's a lot
of people who feel that way Donald Trump
is a polarizing president there are
people who absolutely love the guy they
think he tells it like it is he's a
straight shooter that I like the way he
talks he doesn't weigh his words
carefully like most focus-group
politicians there are people who think
he never should have been president and
they're offended by the fact that he is
in office so a lot of views of the media
are obviously viewed through that prism
if you think Donald Trump is a good or a
great president then you're not gonna
like a lot of the coverage in several
major news organizations if you think
that Donald Trump is a terrible
president you're probably not going to
be a big fan of fox news coverage and
you're probably going to like them his
liberal attackers I try in this book to
to go beyond that to stick to the facts
again there's a lot of reporting in this
book not just about the medium and how
the president deals with the media but
also about his dealings with his staff
who are engaged in a lot of
self-destructive leaks we're seeing that
right now against John Kelly previously
it was against Reince Priebus Ivanka
Trump Jared Kushner and Steve Bannon got
into the varying finger-pointing battles
about who was leaking about whom so as a
journalist I try to stick to the facts I
know everybody out there has opinions
that's healthy this is our guest Howard
Kurtz the
Media madness Donald Trump the press and
the war over the truth joining us
Chester Virginia Republican line mark go
ahead good morning gentlemen uh how are
you love your show I can have a question
that we we never find any up-to-date
ever on the actual ratings like the day
they're legends CNN to like flip the
switch on the coverage and it's been
just bad ever since but I'd like to know
how many folks have actually left
watchin seeing it and moved over to Fox
and the difference of the ranges if you
think those brands are going to make a
difference ain't no with women a woman
comment about she loved the opinion is I
like the opinion see when I was like the
facts but when the opinion is show
statue numbers that were violated
you know stuff that's obviously illegal
then just they may not like what they're
hearing but least you mean you're
telling you exactly what was done wrong
and you did it wrong I mean how could
anybody ignore those facts with the
other stages I know they don't show a
lot of but basically doesn't it makes
money get to them and how do they ignore
when you would make you show you statue
violations that work that we're done
well it's there's an irony here in the
trump presidency miu bring up this
question of ratings CNN's ratings are
higher than they have been in many many
years MSNBC which was really struggling
a few short years ago is having ratings
probably the highest in the history of
that channel now Fox News ratings are
also up and Fox News remains number one
in cable news as has been for almost two
decades but the fact is that taking
particularly in primetime but even
overall taking a more skeptical
aggressive sometimes negative sometimes
unfair approach to President Trump has
helped the other two cable news channels
the New York Times which the president
calls the failing New York Times in fact
these ones called the newspaper evil but
he still continues to talk to the times
this hometown paper which goes to the
sort of love-hate relationship I I
mentioned earlier digital subscriptions
are soaring Washington Post digital
subscriptions are way up so even as both
sides are locked in this increasingly
ugly battle Trump has been a goldmine
for these news organizations and they
prevent present a very big fat target
for him at least with that portion of
the country a growing portion of the
country
and trust the media did Donald Trump
have the same attitude you talk about
his attitude towards the media how did
that change once television entered into
it particularly his television career
and how he treated the media and used
the media Donald Trump always had a sort
of intuitive feel for how to make news
in that New York market which I watched
firsthand when I lived in New York and
covered him even covered his divorce
from Ivana which you had the New York
Daily News and New York Post on opposite
sides won back Donald went back to vana
I remember calling him during that time
and I was the out-of-town reporter for
The Washington Post he's not gonna call
me back on this calls me right back
gives me a few sound bites Donald Trump
knows that controversy sells and that
even when he's getting beat up he knows
and he learned this in New York and it
is true today as president negative
coverage helps this president now that
sounds counterintuitive like you know
who wants to get beat up but when when
when the president is getting beat up on
you know his handling of just about
anything
immigration for example it means that he
dominates the news cycle means that
every story is like attacking Trump
attacking Trump some defend Trump
attacking Trump if Trump then hits back
at the fake media which term that I
don't use and I think that he uses too
often but when he hits back at news
organizations in coverage then that
extends the news cycle because we love
to talk about ourselves
so all that uses up most of the oxidants
was true in the campaign too I mean
everyone said oh he gets all this free
airtime well he gave hundreds of
interviews most of the other candidates
didn't and even when the interviewers
were beating up on him again he's
dominating that news agenda and that's
an important thing even when you're
president even when you've got the big
bully pulpit to be you know some say
well maybe we need a break from don't
rubbish you just go on vacation not
tweet for week that parently is not
happening he just tweeted out actually
this about the Russia investigation he's
saying that I have been much tougher on
Russia than Obama let's look at the
facts total fake news talk about Twitter
how is it it totally changed the the
reporting on this president well for one
thing it means we all work 24/7 I mean
you got up at 6 o'clock good morning
he's already tweeted I go out to get a
sandwich I come back 30 minutes later
the world has changed because he's put
out more tweets it's a very effective
means for him to go through the around
the media filter and communicate
directly with with his people now do I
think and do some many of his closest
advisers as I write in this book believe
that sometimes he goes too far
he shouldn't be giving disparaging
nicknames to political opponents and and
journalists he did this with Joe
Scarborough Mika Brzezinski on MSNBC
there's all back story in the book about
their relationship once friendly now
very hostile and sometimes he does it to
distract as I mentioned earlier but it's
not something that is going to end all
the Kellyanne Conway and the rest
they've all know that they can't take
away his phone that this is part of who
he is he believes it up and get elected
whether it can can he tone he's toned it
down at times and I think that has
helped him but then inevitably something
ticks him off
he watches something on cable news in
fact this whole tweet storm over the
weekend in response to Muller's
indictment of the 13 Russians very much
had to do with the president initially
claimed vindication but as he saw a lot
of criticism because he hasn't he says
I've done more against Russia but he
what he hasn't done this is this was a
terrible attack on our country and
they're gonna be retaliation he's got a
lot Kristen for that which in turn
formal press conference as this
president has had how do they compare
with the previous administrations but
also how much access to this Donald
Trump give them
if you just measured by for press
conferences it's very local he's done
basically one and that is really far but
journalists will tell you private
many it's just about everyday he's
stopping to take questions I'll answer a
couple of questions at a photo-op
he'll stand by the helicopter and take
questions so he photographers say they
have more access to this president and
then there's the off-the-record part I
mentioned NBC's Chuck Todd he's had
several off-the-record meetings with
president even though the president
publicly criticizes him and what happens
as I described in this book is that the
president starts out yelling at Chuck
over something he said or something
NBC's reported Chuck yells back and then
they settled down to a civil
conversation and to the end of one of
these meetings Chuck Todd turned into a
hope hexa communications director and
said we just can't quit each other from
Rochester New York independent line
Carol hello good morning I think that I
used to watch Fox and MSNBC I perform or
hard news I skip the opinion people but
I think both you know both sides tell
the truth they just emphasize different
stories that maybe suit their worldview
or philosophy because they would switch
from one channel to another and you
wouldn't hear anything about what the
other people were saying and I will say
that I stopped watching the cable news
and my life is so much better
I just I don't miss it at all do what
she can but I tell you it just makes
everybody crazy I mean sprager walked
across president Trump says they'd be on
there for a half an hour
Thank You Carol preciate it well you
know there are people who I think are
turned off by the contentious and
sometimes polarized nature of cable news
and this applies to all the channels and
especially because you know the politics
in the Trump ear seem so polarized I can
see where it's just an overload there
are even days Saturday when I may not
turn on the TV just to get a break
I understand people just kind of wanting
to maybe watch c-span instead on your
earlier point it is I do notice and I
sometimes comment about this in my
columns on Fox News calm or on my media
bus program the the story is favorable
to president Trump it may get more play
on certain channels and vary
and then you flip it a negative story
maybe go wall-to-wall particularly in
primetime you know I've noticed a
pattern here in the book I call them
evening earthquakes the New York Times
The Washington Post will pop an
investigative story usually around 7:30
8 o'clock at night it's gonna be in the
next day's paper they put it online and
then CNN and MSNBC pretty much can go
wall-to-wall and often having reporters
in those papers who contributors on to
talk about it Fox may deal with it
somewhat differently and these you know
my advice to people is always like being
informed consumer don't just stay in a
bubble if you're of one political stripe
or another see what the other side is
saying that's how you form the rest
opinions rather than just being in an
echo chamber how much of these reports
that you see are based on unnamed
sources and does that trend increased
with this coverage of the administration
has that always been a consistent way to
many and it's increased and I as an old
investigative reporter I always say that
there were some stories that cannot be
reported without unnamed sources because
people could lose their jobs or be at
risk if they're exposing wrongdoing but
the word it's getting perverted and just
way overused
is in political stories where it's just
people taking potshots anonymously the
papers are supposed to have rules about
that but they're often violated here's a
classic example so John Kelly
understandably the chief of staff is
under a lot of heat for the Rob Porter
mess he's the fired presidential aide
who had the allegations of abuse from
two ex-wives a lot of leaks from other
White House officials and other Trump
advisors against Kelly who I guess is
struggling to sort of keep his whole the
general struggling to keep his hold on
the staff but the Washington Post quoted
one White House official anonymously
from without having to put the person's
name on the line saying that Kelly was a
big fat liar well I don't think that's
the kind of thing that be should be said
anonymously you want to make the case as
to where you think he deviated in
telling his story and Kelly did make
mistakes in the handling this there is
no question then do that but when you
have one side saying big fat liar or
he's got he's running a cover-up
I don't think that we as journalists in
a political story that's not as it
should be granting anonymity for those
kind of potshots from New York Rego Park
New York Democrats line Michael go ahead
I
I just have a question for the guests
and that is in four years now a sense of
seventies the FBI has always gone after
protesters peace anti-war
environmentalist I remember reading a
story once where they went after
inspired on the Boy Scouts and the
women's groups because they were
anti-war but and then they had them
labeled terrorists if you're
demonstrating that a wall street or a
Treehugger in a March they would call it
a terrorist organization that I'm
wondering I want to ask you why isn't
anybody calling the Russians terrorists
okay caller things well I think they're
cyber terrorists is the term that I
would use there's no question that this
was a coordinated effort apparently with
the indirect blessing of the Russian
government to attack American democracy
not with bombs or bullets but with a
campaign of disruption that by the way
wasn't just you know a lot of posts on
Facebook and some fake Twitter
identities the indictment returned last
week shows some of these Russians
impersonated Americans engaged in
identity theft you phony social security
numbers so this was a pretty broad
attack I mean you you're poor by the FBI
in past decades certainly and this has
been investigated and exposed you know
FBI was used for political purposes I
know people think the FBI's role in the
Russian investigation right now is
controversial but I think the worst
excesses of the past have have been
corrected after a lot of public exposure
as far after as your other point I think
I've addressed that the couple lines
from the book just to show you how the
media and you referenced this before the
media have become more tribal their
outlets often serving as a badge of
personal identity conservatives and
liberals from fans and Trump bachelors
have split into ideological camps I'm
willing to tolerate the slightest
deviation from their side wedded to
their version of the truth
well I've I go through this
and this is not just about my book you
know I will do a show in which I will
have guests of different opinions Pro
and anti Trump and I will try to present
the facts and then I will go on Twitter
and I will read simultaneously from the
same segment you have been a Trump hater
since day one why should we trust you
and the others will say you are so far
in the tank for Donald Trump that it's
pathetic what I say is I'm not Pro Trump
I'm not anti Trump I'm Pro reality I'm
Pro good journalism and that was the
point that I was trying to hammer home
here which is some people are so wedded
to their ideology that they're not
really that interested in fairness they
want presentation in the media that that
supports their own views what's the
worst criticism you ever got from the
president this is fascinating because I
bumped into him in the White House a few
months ago and he somehow you know
managed either people tell him we
somehow seized what I would I do and he
says your problem Howie is that you're
two down the middle and I said well mr.
president in my world that's a
compliment but he's always working the
refs he once told me I was too neutral
which is of course my job so if that's
the worst worst criticism that's okay
it has been interesting to watch his
evolution and the earlier point about
people's ideological opinions I believe
the coverage of the president and I've
laid this out in great detail is it goes
beyond ideology because you know look
every conservative Republican president
you go back to Reagan you go back to
George W Bush didn't have a lot of
sympathetic when it came to policies
with this president there's something
more personal more visceral the way he
talks he can sound like the guy in the
bar a lot of people like that he doesn't
sound like a politician who chooses
every syllable carefully should a
president choose his words more
carefully than he does at I'm sure but
that's why ideology is not the only
prism through which to view the coverage
you have to look at what it is about
Donald Trump that so gets under the skin
of so many journalists this is Patricia
from Minneapolis Republican line oh good
morning
nice to talk to you mr. Kurtz I was the
lady hi the lady from New York touched
on what I'd like to say one
my point please don't cut cut me off
Peter I have more than one she mentioned
how the media she would one side
wouldn't be talking about anything the
mainstream media has become so on hand
and so personal and so equal on a
constant negative coverage of President
Trump but what the other thing is is
they don't talk about his
accomplishments the good economy all of
the things that he's actually done
cutting regulations they avoid all of
that and just talk for it
so awfully about him as a person all ad
hominem attack the other thing is is
c-span itself they read from all of the
liberal papers Washington Post New York
Times article article after article
including the Washington Times including
the Washington Examiner including other
conservative sources so so we'll just
leave it there mr. Kurtz take what you
want okay you know there have been times
as I show in this book where the
president has gotten rare amounts of
positive coverage for example the
bombing in Syria after the chemical
attacks by Assad even some of his most
liberal critics applauded that and said
it was something that Barack Obama
hadn't done but by and large for the
whole first year president was measured
by the press for how much he got through
Congress which wasn't much particularly
with the failed effort to repeal and
replace Obamacare when he finally passed
the tax cuts there were a number of
stories that said you know he didn't
have that bad a year despite what you've
heard the last 11 months he got the
major tax cut bill through he has a
slash regulations the economy is doing
well so there was some sort of grudging
acknowledgment that the president was
being more effective than perhaps most
journalists were allowing but what often
happens in these moments he give us a
good speech to Congress he did it last
year and then the State of the Union was
a pretty good speech is that in our
speeding up news cycle it lasts a day a
day and a half and then suddenly well
there's a new Russia investigation let's
go chase this let's go chase that what
about this hurricane how do you handle
that and so whatever
positive coverage this president gets
tends to be overtaken by other events
and sometimes tends to be overtaken by
his own tweets and he knows that these
tweets drive news coverage you can see
that every day so there were some times
when he kind of steps on his own good
news perhaps inadvertently what do you
think about the coverage of his
relationship with past porn stars
allegedly or Playboy models or women
who've claimed that he is ultimate what
do you think about that as far as the
coverage of Donald Trump I have the
impression that neither of these latest
two cases have been as big stories as
they might have been because I think it
involves his private life a decade ago I
think it sort of baked into the cake
people knew they weren't electing a
choirboy as president no it reminds me a
little bit of Bill Clinton after
Jennifer flowers other things in the 92
campaign the difference I would say is
that you have in two cases now
allegations of hush money being paid in
one case by the president's personal
lawyer two former porn star storming
Daniels he says it's not hush money but
he hasn't fully explained what that
hundred thirty thousand dollars was in
the other case you have allegations
about the National Enquirer buying the
story of the former employment
appointment and then not publishing if
there's some dispute about the facts
there that seems to me to be more recent
and more troublesome and I'm not sure
that story has gone away are these
tabloid stories whenever I talked about
the Ohio you're just going tablet well
yeah but the same thing I did in 1998
when Bill Clinton was embroiled with the
allegations and was sure not to be true
about Monica Lewinsky as well as other
women in his life sometimes we live in a
tabloid world and we can't escape
covering that from New York independent
line Mike go ahead Howard sir yes love
your show and basically when I can't see
it I basically record it I'm doing a
touch on a couple of points that you
made as far as Trump is concerned with
the outlet that he has to the press
basically he will talk to anybody and
everybody and that's the one thing I
like about him and maybe cliche he's a
regular guy he's not a politician you
know Barack Obama Clinton Bush they all
just basically pulled off wouldn't say
anything to begin with I can't wait to
see that did you read your book but my
question to you
do you think he'll ever be liked and
what I'm talking about as far as the
running against Biden and he's got to
come up I probably go against them
what do you how do you feel about how
people are going to perceive him in in
the next two to three years well I
thought once he became president because
you know whatever people might say
negatively about Donald Trump you know
like anybody in public life he can be a
very charming guy he can turn it on he
even was making nice with Chuck and
Nancy Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi until
more recent troubles in negotiating
compromises on immigration but it hasn't
happened and I think it part of it is
the and and the reason I'm not
particularly optimistic at least about a
good warm or at least respectful
relationship within the president in the
press is that both sides have strong
incentives to keep this warfare up well
the president's gonna go to the gridiron
dinner maybe that's a bit of a an olive
branch as I said the news organizations
many of them not all reporters at every
organization I do would sometimes paint
with too broad a brush are are playing
or are getting a big audience for
commentary for reporting for
investigations that seem to be largely
an anti-trump and the president uses the
press as a foil when he doesn't like a
story he attacks the press when he wants
to change this up if he attacks the
press it works for him more than any
other president that I have seen now
what right now it's all about Donald
Trump we get into 2019 and 2020 and
there are Democratic candidates running
and ultimately a nominee then it's going
to be how do you feel about this
president what he's done wrong and right
over the last three or four years versus
a living breathing human being who also
has a record and that's going to change
the coverage somewhat as it always does
Cindy is in Windsor Connecticut
Democrats line good morning so I guess I
won I have a couple at one point that I
wanted to make and I mean isn't it true
that legislation changes take really two
to four years to really have an effect
on the economy and what we see so you
know I find that we keep making these
comments
you know just trumping in office for you
know less than two years and the
economy's doing well I mean isn't that
from what was done in the previous
administration well there's no question
that Donald Trump inherited a relatively
good economy from Barack Obama when he
took office in 2017 unemployment was
already pretty low at the same time that
has continued and despite the recent
reverses in the stock market I mean the
the Dow is way up compared to what it
was when he took office and I always say
the president's get too much credit when
the stock of art goes up and too much
blame when it goes down few people and
the press talked about Trump's role and
when the Dow was soaring as soon as it
went down you heard a lot more well
maybe this is trumps for some
legislative changes take a couple years
to have an impact but not tax cuts I
mean the beginning this month I believe
the tax cuts are taking effect and
people are seeing it in their paychecks
but that Scott was not popular when it
was passed unusual if people usually
like to get tax cuts but I suppose our
show me is getting a little more popular
now that it seems rhibs a lot of people
didn't think they were going to get it
they looked at the ideological battle
and said well that's for someone else
it's not for me so I think it sure is it
orally - the issue with definitive
judgment on president Trump's impact on
the economy after a year in a couple
months in office yeah I would say it is
but at the same time he hasn't done
anything to impede the growth that most
people have felt particularly if you own
stocks and bonds we're running short on
time Joe from Garland Texas Republican
lying go right ahead yes I was just like
to make the statement I'm 84 years old
there was a time in my life when Walter
Cronkite reported his news they played
you might not agree with him you knew it
was a Cruz and then along came Dan
Rather and then this is where we are
today thank you dan Rather instantly
enough is still active and has become
very anti Trump so he's obviously more
in an opinion mode now look there was a
time when you know huntley-brinkley
Walter Cronkite had a lot of respect
most Americans got their news from the
three Network newscasts that time is
long on social media the internet cable
news it's a much more fractured and
polar
Media universe and that has created a
lot of niches for a lot more opinion and
analysis punditry
the days of Cronkite and I knew Walter
Cronkite in a great respect for him but
they're not coming back
as far as your own show and your own
profession how do you personally keep
editorial controls on what you report
and put on the air I have complete
independence to put on the air what I
want to say what I want to analyze the
way I want that means if I make a
mistake it's on me we all make mistakes
and I try to keep that in mind and
people sometimes think and I got this
one I've worked for other news
organizations well you're just following
this line or that line because I'm a
media critic it means I'm not real
popular in the business because too
often I have to call out colleagues who
have made a mistake
sometimes they journalists can tend to
be rather thin-skinned let's put it that
way
but when I decided to do this I decided
that the only way I could do it was to
not only be aggressive about journalism
and cover it like any other beat but
also to take on my employer when
necessary that was true with the watch
post true at CNN true now at Fox if Fox
makes a mistake does something wrong
over plays or under plays the story I
talk about and I ask people their
opinions of it I think that in the end
that adds to your credibility people see
that you're willing to hold everyone to
the same standard as far as your
personal show media bus host what's the
format and when is it on oh it is on
every Sunday 11:00 Eastern somebody said
it should be on daily but that's not
happening right now we take a look you
know we don't just talk about politics
in Trump we take a look at sports
controversies cultural controversies
Hollywood sexual harassment cases which
was very much in the news and we do it
with a balance panel we try to get news
makers on and we have a lot of fun doing
it we take it seriously but we have a
lot of fun doing it how long have you
been doing this show I've been at Fox
now four years I'm doing the show there
I did my own version of the show at CNN
for 16 years I was at the Washington
Post for nearly 30 years so when I
criticized the mainstream media I'm a
product of the media I know its
strengths and weaknesses Howard Kurtz is
the author of media madness Donald Trump
the press the war over truth and thank
you for being our guest great to be I
really enjoyed it we are going to
continue on with open phones or the last
half hour for the program however the
house is in a pro forma session which
means
come in they'll gavel in do some
rudimentary business and then gavel out
again when they come out we'll go to
open phones so let me give you the
numbers so you can start calling 202
seven four eight eight thousand one for
Republicans it's 202 seven four eight
eight thousand for Democrats and it's
202 seven four eight eight thousand two
again if you want to make your thoughts
known on the phone lines choose the line
that best represents you you can also
put on our social media site at c-span
w-j and you can also go to our website
at cspan or a facebook page at
facebook.com slash c-span this is ditte
let's try to squeeze in one more call to
see if we can get it in before open
halts mr. kritzky don't mind nampa idaho
independent line go ahead I wish again
then go ahead real question are you
doing uh-huh yeah well I actually had a
question for Howard on why he thought
maybe Trump would get reelected with all
the Standells going on and everything
else that involves Donald Trump I'm a
Vietnam veteran the country severely
just divided DC as probes
okay thanks caller we need we need who
knows two years from now is a lifetime
in politics I did say that I didn't
underestimate his ability to get elected
on my show on the Sunday before the
election everybody said Hillary New York
Times 98 percent I said Donald Trump
could win the media shouldn't rush to
judgment here but the next election is a
long way off Howard Kurtz of the book
Media Matters thanks again